WHARF THEATER ON SATURDAY
JANUARY 22ND TICKETS GO ON
SALE THIS FRIDAY MORNING
THROUGH TICKETMASTER DOT COM.
IT IS TIME TO PAUSE FOR MEN AHS FOR IT'S 16TH
A PAUSE, THE MUSICAL THE
HILARIOUS SHOW HAS RETURNED TO HISTORIC YEAR AND WE HAVE 'EARTH
MOTHER"
HARRIS CABARET INSIDE HARRIS
FOR ITS 16TH HISTORIC HERE.
AND WE HAVE EARTH MOTHER
HERSELF FROM THE SHOW. VE TO
KAREEM YOU JOINING US TODAY 16
YEARS ME THAT'S A LOT OF MEN
OF FOG.
NOT SEEING US TELL US WHAT
TO EXPECT.
WELL IT'S IT'S GOING TO
HAVE YOU LAUGHING FROM THE
TIME YOU WALK INTO THE TIME
YOU LEAVE AND YOU'RE GOING TO
FEEL BETTER WHEN YOU BECAUSE
IT'S A SISTER AND THE REASON
WE'RE THE LONGEST RUNNING
VEGAS HISTORY IS BECAUSE IT'S
FUNNY IT'S RELATED BOWL.
PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY'RE PART
OF I'VE BEEN DOING IT THE
WHOLE TIME, I'M THE ONLY
ORIGINAL LEFT I'VE BEEN DOING
IT SO LONG AND FINALLY ENDED
YOU TELL US ABOUT YOUR
CHARACTER WHO IS EARTH MOTHER
WHAT IS SHE ALL ABOUT.
WELL MY WE KNOW THE
CHARACTERS HAVE NAMES THEY
HAVE LIKE AN EXPLANATION SO
I'M OR KIND OF LIKE A A REJECT
FROM THE 60'S, YOU KNOW, I'M
ALL ABOUT AND SPIRIT, YOU KNOW
WHERE TO I'M RELEASING
EVERYTHING AND LETTING IT THE
OTHER CHARACTERS ARE TO
BATES CITY FOR THE FIRST TIME
AGING SOAP STAR. SO PEOPLE
WOMEN AND EVEN MEN CAN RELATE
TO THAT ON EVERY LEVEL THAT
THE SHOW IS FUNNY TO BEGIN
WITH HAVE YOU EVER HAD ANY
ONSTAGE EMBARRASSING MOMENTS.
OH MY GOSH OF HAPPENS I FEARED
OR ANYTHING CAN WELL I CAN
TELL YOU ONE THAT COMES TO
MIND THAT WAS PROBABLY THE
MOST EMBARRASSING MOMENT WAS
WHEN MY CHARACTER SHE'S SHE'S
SHE'S JUST WANT TO A WORKOUT
SESSION AND SHE'S LIKE HUFFING
AND PUFFING IN A TRACK SUIT
AND AS I BENT OVER YOU KNOW
KIND OF SHOWING MY DERRIERE TO
THE AUDIENCE. THERE WAS A
SOUND LISTS WITH THIS BALL AND
IT WAS JUST PERFECT TIMING
RIGHT THAT THAT HAPPENS.
I'VE HEARD NOTHING BUT
GREAT THINGS ABOUT IT NOW TELL
EVERYONE WHEN DOES THE SHOW
RIGHT HOW CAN THEY SEE IT.
WELL THE SHOW IS THAT HARRAH'S
LAS VEGAS.
WE HAVE SHOWS ON TUESDAYS
FOR AN 8 THE SHOWS ON SATURDAY
FOR AN 08:00AM MONDAY
08:00PM DARK ON SUNDAYS.
BE PREPARED TO LAUGHED IT
IS THE LONGEST-RUNNING
SCRIPTED MUSICAL IN LAS VEGAS
HISTORY. WHAT DO YOU SAY 16
MORE YEARS AFTER THIS.
OH HECK. YEAH HAHA.
IT IS DELIGHTED SO MANY
AUDIENCE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
MUSICAL WILL PERFORM MONDAY
THROUGH SATURDAY AT 08:00PM
WITH A 04:00PM MATINEE ON
SATURDAY AND TUESDAY IF YOU
WANT YOUR TICKETS ALL YOU HAVE
TO DO IS GO TO MENOPAUSE THE
MUSICAL DOT COM TO PURCHASE